in 1929 the theoretical physicist
albert einstein was very famously asked
if he believed in god
his reply to this question is often
quoted
he responded quote i believe in
spinoza's god
who reveals himself in the lawful
harmony of the world
not in a god who concerns himself with
the fates and the doings of mankind
this statement has later been parroted
by great scientific figures like carl
sagan
all seeming to find something worthwhile
in it and in this thing called spinoza's
god
but what is spinoza's god what did
einstein mean by his statements
and how accurate are discussions about
this today
[Applause]
this video is a collaboration with my
friend zevi from the channel seekers of
unity this is a lovely channel that
talks about all kinds of topics relating
to mysticism
but also philosophy and religion in
general
now what is so great about his channel
is that it opens up for so many
discussions and debate between people
from
different religious and philosophical
backgrounds
and supports an idea of unity and of
understanding between different peoples
and that is
very very admirable it also helps that
zebi himself is just a
lovely guy so i highly recommend you go
over to his channel
subscribe and check out his companion
video to this one where he'll be also
talking about spinoza
and his conception of god
spinoza or more precisely baruch spinoza
was a philosopher who lived in holland
in the 17th
century he is often seen as one of the
most significant philosophers not only
of the modern period but
really of all time his ideas about
things like god and other philosophical
topics
have influenced thinkers up to this very
day
born in amsterdam in 1632 went into a
sephardic jewish community
spinoza quickly showed intellectual
promise as a young man
he came from a moderate family
background and as a young man he would
help his family with their import
business
his intellectual endeavor started early
as already in the first few years of his
adult life
he seems to have already started to
develop some of the unique
and daring ideas for which he would
become so famous later on
some of these ideas did not go down too
well with the jewish authorities in
amsterdam
and in 1656 at the age of 23
he was excommunicated from the sephardic
community
for his so-called monstrous deeds and
abominable heresies
much speculation has been devoted to
what specific reasons he was
excommunicated for
but many will naturally argue that it
had something to do
with the ideas that he would later
present in his philosophical writings
because of this event spinoza left
amsterdam and lived periodically in
various places across holland
primarily settling in the hague for the
rest of his short life he would dedicate
himself to developing his philosophical
ideas
writing many literary works and as a
personal teacher
often doing so under the name of
benedictus or benedict
some of his works include the
theological political treatise
and an exposition on descartes
principles of philosophy
all of which were pretty controversial
at the time but his greatest masterpiece
the
work for which he would primarily become
famous for and which would cement him as
one of the most significant philosophers
in the world
is the ethics written between 1661 and
1675
and published only after his untimely
death in 1677
the ethics has become one of the
classics of modern philosophy
divided into five parts on various
topics
the book is a masterful piece of
philosophy that has also been
very controversial and debated in part
one
of god spinoza presents his arguments
and ideas about god
ideas that as we've seen inspired people
like einstein centuries later
but spinoza's ideas about god can be
quite complex and they aren't always as
simple
as they may appear at first glance he is
often associated with a philosophical or
theological position known as pantheism
pan meaning all and theos meaning god
thus the idea that everything is god or
that god
is everything this is because of the
common understanding that spinoza
identified god
with nature itself and we will get to
this point soon
now this isn't incorrect he certainly
did do
this in in a way but scholars tend to
agree that spinoza's ideas aren't so
crude
and there's a lot more complexity and
nuance going on here
spinoza can be quite hard to interpret
and this is the reason why there has
throughout history been a lot of
different understandings about
what he was actually trying to say since
he lived he has often been called an
atheist because of his supposed
reduction of god to the laws of nature
on the other hand the german romantics
called him a god intoxicated man
both completely different
characterizations but both somewhat
legitimate depending on the perspective
you choose to view him from
but let's not beat around the bush
anymore what are the arguments that
spinoza presents in his
first part of the ethics what indeed
is spinoza's god now keeping in mind
what i have just said that there is some
disagreement and
various understandings of how spinosa
should be read or understood
the basic outline can be said to look
something like this
spinoza talks about something called
substance a concept that goes back to
aristotle and which was used by
philosophers up to his own day
substance can be said to be something
that is independent
something that doesn't require something
else for its existence
quote by substance i understand what is
in itself and is conceived through
itself
and according to most philosophers
including in spinoza's day
there are many many substances in the
world
i have a substance your cat has a
substance
but to spinoza there is only one
substance
an infinite perfect essence with an
infinite number of
attributes of which all things in the
universe are only finite
modes to spinoza this one substance
which is the totality of all existence
the kind of essence of reality itself is
god
he also uses the word nature and
considers this word to be synonymous
with
the word god quote by god
i understand a being absolutely infinite
in other words a substance consisting of
an infinity of
attributes of which each one expresses
an eternal
and infinite essence so right away we
can call spinoza a
monist or more specifically a substance
monist
in other words to spinoza there exists
only one
unified thing that is god or nature
the substance of all things but we
shouldn't view
substance as something material we
aren't talking about substance in the
way that
for example would is the substance of a
table
instead substance could be seen as the
underlying reality of something or in
this case of
all things the substance or or god in
itself
is not finite it is infinite and exists
beyond all limitations this underlying
abstract substance includes the material
aspect in fact it includes it as one of
its infinite attributes
but it is not limited to it and since
there is only one
substance god this means obviously that
there is no other substance
hence everything that is is a parts of
god in some way
and this is the pantheistic facet of his
thinking
quote whatever is is in god
and nothing can be or be conceived
without
god but what does it actually mean to
say that things are
in god is he saying that everything are
simply
parts of a whole the whole being god or
that they are
properties of god in that way this is
one of those questions that has occupied
scholars on this subject
for centuries but what seems clear is
that spinoza
does in some ways differentiate between
god and his attributes on one hand
and the world on the other while the
former is
basically what it is it's god the things
of the world
are described as being modes of god
or modes of god's attributes quote
from the necessity of the divine nature
there must follow
infinitely many things in infinitely
many modes
as we have seen god is infinite in his
essence and has an unlimited and
infinite number of
attributes which are all identical to
the essence of god but
expresses its infinite nature in
different ways
and the modes which make up the universe
are expressions of these attributes
in a line that strongly echoes mystics
like ibn arabi
spinoza says that the modes are called
affections of god's attributes or
modes by which god's attributes are
expressed in a certain
and determinate way in other words
the infinite absolute substance that is
god
is expressed in limited finite form
through the modes of the universe in
this way
everything is god as we saw earlier he
identifies god with
nature and we can see how this naturally
pun intended follows the earlier
statements
nature and its laws are simply direct
expressions of god's nature as such
and when it comes to nature spinoza
considers there to be two
aspects or sides to nature first what he
calls
natura naturans naturing nature the
active principle which causes everything
else and which is directly identical to
god or substance as
creator and secondly there is natura
naturata
natured nature as the name suggests
this is the result of the first aspect
that which is
produced by the active aspect or in
other words natura naturals
and this flows into one of the main
points that scholars disagree on when it
comes to spinoza
does he identify god only with nature in
nature
or is god also identical to natured
nature
this also becomes important for the
question of whether he should be called
a
pantheist so is god in his essence
separated from the universe as being in
some way at least as being the cause of
the universe and
the universe being the modes or
expressions of god's attributes but
still remaining
somewhat distinct or is he also
identifying god completely
with the manifested universe as such
some scholars will argue for the latter
that spinoza completely identifies god
with the created world as well
god simply becomes another word for
nature as a whole
legitimizing them calling him things
like an atheist
others disagree they point to many
sections in the ethics where he seems to
draw a
more clear distinction between the two
god is the cause of the universe
that from which the universe flows but
there is a certain kind of difference
the universe becomes only the finite
expressions or manifestations
the modes of god's infinite attributes
while god himself being infinite remains
bigger than this limited manifestation
or this limited expression
can spinoza then be called a pantheist
well if we go by the latter
theory and also define pantheism as the
complete identification
of god with the created world or the
totality of the world
then he doesn't really seem to fit very
neatly into that category
some have instead suggested that spinoza
should be termed a
pan and theist a belief where god is
imminent and present in all things even
identical to them in some way
but still transcends them in his
totality spinoza's writings are
sometimes cryptic
and it isn't always certain or clear
exactly what he means
which has led to these disagreements
among scholars historically and today
he is called pantheist pan enthus a god
intoxicated man and even an atheist
now i don't claim to be an expert on
spinoza in particular
and i'm not going to attempt to answer
this question right now but
it shows us that things are a lot more
complicated than how
it may appear at first glance what does
seem clear to me
is that spinoza indeed places god as a
central part of his philosophical system
the whole purpose of the ethics is to
lead to the conclusion
that one is to live in constant love for
god
so why with all this in mind why then is
he so often called an
atheist well this is because there are
certain aspects of his theology
that still seems to really clash with
classical theology as expressed in the
abrahamic religions
indeed spinoza completely rejects any
idea of a personal god god is not a
being who
judges or cares about what you eat or
how you pray
he doesn't even create the world
willingly but through the necessity of
his nature
this is a denial of the god who answers
prayers or
speaks in the form of sacred scriptures
spinoza even denies
miracles because everything in the world
must follow the laws of nature
now remember god is nature and if
something was to
break those laws god would be going
against himself
which would be ridiculous that would be
a paradox
to believe in any personal god who
interferes in the world or
cares about the doings of mankind is
superstition
spinoza's god is abstract philosophical
and
impersonal it is because of these views
that spinoza has been such a
controversial figure
and it is the reason why he has been
called an atheist
since he denies that personal god which
according to many are
central tenets of religious belief many
argue that one might as well say that he
doesn't believe in god at all
and thus can be called an atheist
however in my opinion this
is partly a result of a shallow
understanding of
the history and tradition of philosophy
and theology
a lot of the time when spinoza is called
an atheist it is based on a view that
religions only conceive of god as a
personal anthropomorphic being
and often fails to take into
consideration the huge complexity in
depth of theological traditions
and indeed scholarship recognizes more
and more that spinoza was indebted to
his predecessors
not only modern thinkers like dickhart
but also to medieval philosophers like
maimonides
spinoza's view of god while significant
and unique of course
isn't unheard of in earlier philosophy
and theology
as i mentioned earlier the monistic
ideas about a single imminent substance
being the reality of the created world
and
identified with god can be found in
thinkers
mystics like ibn adabi for example
similarly
ideas like the necessity of creation
that god
has to create the world because of his
own nature rather than through
individual will
can also be found in philosophers like
ibn cena and maimonides
both of whom also denied most if not all
anthropomorphic aspects of god
and yet none of those thinkers are
usually considered atheists
for these reasons i don't really see
spinoza as some
radical thinker who revolutionized how
we can understand
god instead i see him as following a
long line of thinkers who
speculated about god in philosophical
and abstract language
and who dared to be a little bold in his
expressions
the main difference between him and some
of the earlier philosophers
and theologians from religions like
judaism christianity and islam
is how unequivocally he denied the
personal god
as mere superstition whereas most of the
earlier thinkers would
try to incorporate that into their
system in some way
either through allegorical readings or
some other argument they would
try to harmonize the paradox between the
personal and impersonal understandings
of god
whereas spinoza chose to cut the ties
between them completely
and that i think is where he can rightly
be called radical
so in conclusion spinoza can be viewed
from many
different perspectives to in many
presentations like in the tv show
cosmos for example he's presented as a
champion of
science and rationalism who stood up
against
the tyranny of religious superstition
this is of course a very strong
post-enlightenment kind of rhetoric or
thinking that
i think fails to take into consideration
a lot of the complexities of his actual
philosophical thoughts
we can call him god intoxicated a
pantheist or even an atheist if we so
wish
but if we limit ourselves to only one of
these fixed conceptual frameworks
we might miss one of the things that are
so exciting about people like spinoza
that they are very hard to fit into a
particular box
it's easy to understand why a person
like einstein would claim to believe in
spinoza's god
hopefully the context of that original
statement is now a little clearer
spinoza offers a god that fits well into
the modern scientific
framework one that can be inspiring even
to staunch atheists
for this reason einstein adored spinoza
so much in fact that he even wrote a
poem about him
the poem isn't very good at all but it
serves as a testament to einstein's
appreciation for espinoza
and his intellectual legacy the poem
goes as follows quote how much do i love
this noble man more than i could say
with words
i fear though he'll remain alone with a
holy halo of his own
you think his example would show us what
this teaching can give humankind
trust not the comforting facade one must
be born
sublime i'll see you next time
this video is brought to you by our
wonderful patreon community
including our saints washif khan greg
corbin
adam sharaby muhammad hanan fikri saya
jafari amalatif stewart cleland
sunny job and muhammad wadasar just one
truth richie abel
rayd kobas thomas blase and oleg
kirovsky
thank you all so much if anyone wants to
support this
channel and help me make these scholarly
academic
videos on various topics relating to
religion or philosophy
i will leave a link to my patreon page
in the description
and you can check it out if you want to
[Music]
foreign